I'd like to show you now how we use
this process to build a machine-learning
based forecaster at a FinTech company,
at my company, Lucena Research.
The first step is to select which
factors do you want to use?
So those are our Xs.
Remember, it can be multi-dimensional.
So these are things like
Bollinger Bands, PE ratio and so on.
Measurable quantities about a company
that can be predictive
of its stock price.
The next step is to select what
is it you want to predict?
Usually we want to predict change in
price, market relative change in price,
or for now we could just think
about that as future price.
These both become our data, our Xs and
our Ys that we used to train the model.
Now that we know what our
predictive factors are and
what Y is going to be,
we need to consider the breadth and
depth of the data that we're going to
use to train the system with.
So that includes, for
instance, time period.
How far back in time do you
want to go to train the system?
And what's your stock universe?
What universe of data,
which symbols are you going to
use to train the system as well?
Now we can train our model.
We can take this data
to produce that model.
We unleash our machine
learning algorithm.
This might be kNN.
It might be a linear regression.
It could be decision tree.
Whatever.
That algorithm takes this data and
converts it into a model.
We're ready now to use that
model to do some prediction.
The way we do that is we measure
the quantities about the stocks that we
want to make a prediction for now.
We measure what those Xs are today,
plug those into the model and
the model should provide us our Y,
or our prediction.